julian mois est de plus en plus près de
ceux d'essence salvador dali était un
des grands maîtres du surréalisme et
coups de théâtre sont immenses toiles
intitulées nuages qui n'a jamais été
exposée dans un musée refait surface à
montréal et des hommes de se dire en
dehors là il y en a des lieux fait là il
y en a beaucoup
cette oeuvre de six mètres par neuf
mètres avait été créée à l'été 1944
comme décor pour le film la maison du
docteur edwardes d'alfred hitchcock et
il avait une petite roue à la main la
commande par monsieur hitchcock à dellys
était d'illustrer leurs rêves
à l'époque la psychanalyse est tout
après la sortie du film
la toile était tombé dans l'oubli c'est
finalement une collectionneuse française
qui l'a vendue aux producteurs de la
nouvelle exposition divina dali en où
l'eau vendue mais un très très bon prix
je ne peux pas en parler mais oui elle
était très accommodante
cette toile évocatrice est une
invitation à nous mettre la tête dans
les nuages
on peut il projeté comme disait félix ce
qu'on veut une oeuvre d'art c'est ça moi
depuis que je le que je le connais que
je l' ai vu je retourne devant un vrai
siège fait mais je vois le nuage de deux
délits on n'arrive pas l'oublier inverse
cela la proposition dans le
dans le cerveau est inversé les
polarités nuage fera partie d'une
exposition intitulée divina dali et
regroupant santé stampe réalisé par dali
dans les années 1950 pour rendre hommage
au sang champ du chef-d'oeuvre la divine
comédie du poète italien dante se divise
en trois phases you l'enfer le
purgatoire et le paradis
on présente vraiment les 100 oeuvres et
par le plus merveilleux des hasards
c'est 700 ans après le décès de dents
c'est donc je dis que je trie en génie
je le dis on le rapport à mes
contemporains salvador dali décédé en
1989 a été sans aucun doute un des
grands génies du 20e siècle
satwa nuage nouvellement débarqué à
montréal pourrait y rester encore pour
longtemps
on rêve de lui trouver son endroit
permanent où l'installer à montréal dans
mon rêve à moi c'est là quelque qu'elle
doit rester
l'exposition divina dali est présenté au
grand quai du port de montréal dès le 16
juillet ici oui je déprimais radio
canada montréal